Tenemos varios tipos de inteligencias:
el razonamiento deductivo, la inteligencia emocional y la espacial;
hay quizá 100 tipos diferentes de inteligencias, agrupadas,
y cuya fuerza varía en función de cada individuo.
Y si miramos en el reino animal, tienen otros tipos agrupados
en otras sinfonías de diversas inteligencias,
y a veces se tocan con la ayuda de los mismos instrumentos
que usamos los humanos.
Los animales pueden pensar de manera similar pero organizarse diferentemente;
a veces más eficientemente que los humanos,
como en el caso de la fenomenal memoria a largo plazo de la ardilla
que le ayuda a recordar dónde enterró sus nueces,
pero en otros casos, no tanto.
Cuando hacemos máquinas, las diseñamos de la misma manera,
dotando a algunas
con tipos de inteligencia mucho más elevados que la nuestra,
y muchas otras con tipos muy por debajo porque no les hace falta tal nivel.
Así que tomaremos estas cosas, estos grupos artificiales,
y le añadiremos más tipos de cognición artificial a nuestra IA.
La haremos más y más específica.
Por lo que su computador ya ofrece mejores resultados aritméticos,
y el GPS es más listo en la navegación espacial;
y Google, Bing, en la memoria a largo plazo.
Una vez más, tomaremos estos diferentes tipos de pensamiento
y los insertaremos en un auto, por ejemplo.
La razón por la que queremos añadirlos en la conducción
es porque un auto no conduce, no piensa como nosotros.
Este es su punto fuerte.
No se distrae.
No le importa si dejó el horno en marcha
o si debe graduarse en finanzas.
Solo conduce.
(Risas)
Solo hace esto, ¿sí?
De hecho podemos llegar a darlas a conocer
como "libres de conciencia".
No tiene conciencia, no se preocupa por otras cosas,
no se distrae.
En general, lo que estamos tratando de hacer
es diversificar los diferentes tipos de pensamiento lo máximo posible,
poblar este espacio con todo tipo de pensamiento.
De hecho, ya existen algunos retos muy difíciles
en el mundo de los negocios o de la ciencia
que nuestro tipo de pensamiento humano no podrá resolver solo.
Hará falta un plan en dos fases para inventar nuevas formas de pensar
para ayudar a resolver esos problemas realmente grandes,
como la energía oscura o la gravedad cuántica.
Estamos construyendo inteligencias alienígenas,
podemos verlas como una especie de alienígenas artificiales
de alguna manera,
que nos ayudarán a pensar de otra forma,
de una manera diferente.
Serán el motor de la creatividad, de la riqueza y la nueva economía.
La segunda consecuencia de todo esto
es que prácticamente usaremos la IA
básicamente para hacer una segunda revolución industrial.
La primera revolución industrial se basó
en la invención de la fuerza artificial.
Antes de que esto sucediera, durante la revolución agrícola,
todo lo que se fabricaba
era a base de fuerza manual, humana o animal.
Era la única manera de hacer las cosas.
La gran innovación de la revolución industrial
fue aprovechar la energía del vapor y los combustibles fósiles,
para producir esta fuerza artificial y usarla para hacer lo que queríamos.
Hoy, mientras uno conduce por la autopista,
a través de un botón, está al mando de 250 caballos,
la fuerza de 250 caballos,
poder que usamos para construir rascacielos, ciudades, carreteras,
en fábricas que producirán en cadena sillas y neveras,
más allá de nuestra propia fuerza.
Y esta fuerza artificial
también puede distribuirse por una red de cableado
a cada casa, fábrica, granja,
y comprada por cada uno de nosotros, simplemente enchufando algo.
También supuso una fuente de innovación
porque un agricultor podría agregarle a una bomba manual
esta fuerza artificial, la electricidad,
y conseguir así una bomba eléctrica.
Y si eso se multiplica por miles, o decenas de miles de veces,
uno tiene una fórmula para implementar la revolución industrial.
Todo lo que vemos, el progreso del que ahora disfrutamos,
deriva de sus aplicaciones.
Y ahora estamos haciendo lo mismo con la IA.
La distribuiremos a través de una red,
para tomar esta bomba eléctrica,
añadirle la inteligencia artificial, y tener así una bomba inteligente.
Y esto, multiplicado por millones de veces,
será la segunda revolución industrial.
Aquel auto en la autopista
tendrá la fuerza de 250 caballos pero, además, 250 cerebros.
Es el auto autónomo,
un nuevo producto, con nuevo servicios.
La IA estará presente en la red, la nube,
fluirá cómo la electricidad.
Así que todo lo que hemos electrificado tendrá cognificación.
Y entonces, se lo debo a Jeff,
esto de que la fórmula para las siguientes 10 000 startups
es muy, muy simple y consiste en tomar la 'x' y añadirle IA.
Esta es la fórmula y esto es lo que vamos a hacer,
y así haremos la segunda revolución industrial.
Y, por cierto, ahora mismo es posible ir a Google
y comprar IA por seis centavos; cien resultados.
La IA está disponible en el acto.
El tercer aspecto es que al tomar la IA y darle forma
obtenemos robots.
Estos robots se convertirán en 'bots'
y harán la mayoría de las tareas que como humanos ya hicimos.
Un trabajo consiste en tareas,
y estos bots redefinirán la naturaleza de este trabajo,
ya que realizarán algunas de estas tareas,
pero a la vez también se encargarán de nuevas categorías de tareas,
que ni sabíamos que queríamos hacerlas hasta ahora.
De hecho, crearán nuevos trabajos, nuevas tareas que querremos realizar,
del mismo modo que la automatización se encargó de nuevas operaciones
que ni supimos que las necesitábamos y de las cuales no podemos prescindir.
Así que más bien crearán nuevos puestos de trabajo que quitarlos
pero es importante que gran parte de las tareas que les asignemos
sean definidas respecto a su eficiencia o productividad.
Si podemos detallar una tarea, sea manual o conceptual,
entonces podemos definir su eficiencia o productividad
y asignarla a los bots.
La productividad es para los robots.
Nosotros básicamente somos buenos en perder el tiempo.
(Risas)
Somos muy buenos en cosas ineficientes.
La ciencia es instrínsecamente ineficiente.
Se basa en el hecho de que hay que fallar una y otra vez,
que hay que hacer pruebas y experimentos que no funcionan,
o de lo contrario uno no está aprendiendo.
Se basa en el hecho de que no es tan eficiente.
La innovación, por definición, no es eficiente, porque se hacen prototipos,
porque hay que probar cosas que fracasan, que no funcionan.
La exploración es instrínsecamente ineficiente.
El arte no es eficiente.
Tampoco las relaciones humanas.
Estos son los tipos de cosas que nos interesan
porque no son eficientes.
La eficiencia es para los robots.
También aprenderemos a trabajar con estas inteligencias
porque piensan diferente.
Cuando Deep Blue venció al mejor campeón del mundo de ajedrez,
la gente pensó que era el final de este deporte.
Pero de hecho, resulta que hoy,
el mejor campeón del mundo de ajedrez no es una IA.
Y tampoco es un humano,
sino un equipo formado por una IA y un humano.
El mejor que da un diagnóstico no es ni un médico ni una IA,
sino un equipo conjunto.
Trabajaremos con estas inteligencias artificiales en el futuro,
y creo que se nos va a pagar
en función de la calidad de nuestra colaboración con estos bots.
Estos son los tres aspectos: son diferentes;
son servicios y también algo con lo que debemos colaborar, no competir.
Trabajaremos con ellos, no contra ellos.
Así que, ¿dónde nos lleva esto en el futuro?
Creo que dentro de 25 años, miraremos hacia atrás,
y al ver lo que comprendíamos de la IA, diremos:
"No teníamos IA en aquel entonces, y tampoco Internet,
si lo comparamos con lo que tendremos en 25 años".
No hay expertos en IA en este momento.
Atrae mucho dinero, se gastan miles de millones de dólares en esto,
es un negocio enorme.
Pero no tenemos expertos, si lo comparamos con lo que tendremos dentro de 20 años,
así que estamos al principio de todo.
esta es la primera hora de esta época.
En la primera hora de Internet,
de todo lo que queda por llegar.
El producto inteligente más popular en 20 años, el que todos usaremos,
aún no se ha inventado.
Y esto significa que aún están a tiempo.
Gracias.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)